at this altitude I can my hands this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand
and listen to a lot of and watch many of
the same classes over and over but I'm
kind of promiscuous and also enjoy
classes from a lot of the other
instructors they have peloton and
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was
and work tremendously to keep me pushing
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings the
studio experience right to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer go to one
peloton calm
that's o-n-e peloton PE l oto and.com
and enter the code Tim all caps at
checkout and get $100 off of accessories
with your policy on bike purchase so get
a great workout at home anytime you want
check it out go to one peloton calm and
use the code Tim to get started this
episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times just search
Matt Mullenweg tequila Ferriss for quite
an exciting time whether you're looking
to create a personal blog a business
site or both you can make a really big
impact right out of the box when you
build on wordpress.com and you'll be in
good company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 538 TechCrunch Ted CNN and
time just to name a handful and one of
my friends at Google shall remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable end quote and it's one of
the many reasons that nearly 30 percent
of the Internet is run on WordPress you
do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that therefore 24/7
support and they're very very response
if you've questions they get right back
to you and this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period when my
friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you so learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15%
off a brand new website check it out
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
my guest today is Greg McEwan that is
spelled MC ke o WN Greg is the author of
The New York Times bestseller
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less and the founder of
McEwen Inc a company with a mission to
teach essentialism to millions of people
around the world their clients include
Adobe Apple Airbnb Cisco Google Facebook
you may have recognized a few of these
picks our Salesforce calm semantic
Twitter VMware Yahoo and many others
MacEwan is an accomplished public
speaker and has spoken to hundreds of
audiences around the world and in 2012
he was named a young global leader by
the World Economic Forum originally from
London England McEwen now lives in
Silicon Valley with his wife and their
four children he could be found at
Gregory McEwen on Twitter and at Greg
McEwen dot-com Greg welcome to the show
it's so great to be with you Tim and I'm
looking here at a table in front of me
with many many pieces of paper spread
out and they consist of printed out
highlights from your book your book is
one of the most highlighted books that I
have on my Kindle and I wanted to first
and foremost thank you for writing it
because I found it tremendously helpful
personally and it has become one of the
few books that I revisit on a regular
basis so first off I just want to
express gratitude for you
written the book well that's that's
awfully nice of you to do that today
there that's a very humbling here I was
thinking we're going to have a bad
conversation and now now I feel no I
feel like we might go somewhere you know
the secret to happiness low expectations
so it's nowhere to go but from here and
I it's it's also a a book I mentioned in
that way because I don't want to create
the illusion that I have some type of
set it and forget it solution where the
setting of priority or priorities is not
an ongoing project at all times or at
least very frequently something that
needs to be revisited so I'm looking
forward to digging into a number of
different topics and portions of the
book and as well as many things that are
not in the book but perhaps for those
people who don't know could you just
tell a little bit about the the genesis
of essentialism whether that is sort of
the concept or the focus itself or the
book well I mean one of the initiating
moments was when I received an email
from my you know colleague at the time
saying look Friday between one or two
would be a very bad time for your wife
to have a baby because you know I need
you to be at this client meeting and you
know especially in hindsight I'm sure
they were joking or at least half joking
about that but somehow I was enough
stressed in that moment or at that time
between all the different competing
expectations responsibilities that as we
go into the hospital it's Thursday night
we're in the middle of you know the
daughters born in the middle of the
night Friday comes along and I am still
feeling torn and I'm still feeling like
I probably ought to go how can i go how
can i keep everybody happy how can i how
can i do both and and and so you know to
my shame I I went to the meeting
remember afterwards being told you know
look the client
respect you for the choice you just made
and I don't know that they did I didn't
know that they did feel that the look on
their faces didn't events that sort of
confidence to me but but even if they
had you know it's obvious to you to me
is everybody listening that I made a
fool's bargain yeah I violated something
more important more essential for
something less important but less
essential and what I learned from that
was the simplest of lessons which is if
you don't prioritize your life someone
else will and and so that gave me fire
for the deed to to really dig into the
subject to try and understand better why
it is that we we make these kinds of
prioritization decisions and what we can
do to be perhaps better at it and to
actually live our life according to the
things that we've identified as
mattering most and at that time on that
Friday when you took that meeting what
type of what type of work were you doing
what was your profession
I've spent you know 20 years in this
field generally so that's leadership
development it's it's writing it's
research it's it's I was working with
Silicon Valley companies at the time and
so so there was a secondary part to this
story which is that that I was already
working with these companies and noticed
a predictable pattern there at a
professional level which is that these
companies in the early days would be
very focused on you know this is what
we're trying to do sort of a phase of
clarity and their clarity would lead to
success there was real alignment between
if you knew exactly what you were trying
to do at the right time then you could
generate success and then I noticed that
success breeds lots of options and
opportunities for these companies well
that sounds like the right problem to
have but it does in fact turn out to be
a problem if it leads to what Jim cons
is called the undisciplined pursuit of
more if these companies are they often
would fall into the undisciplined
pursuit of more it would lead them to
make this
in such a way that they would plateau in
their progress or even start to fail
altogether so I named that the success
paradox and so it was absolutely the
combination of observing this phenomenon
inside of these organizations and then
suddenly observing it in my own life
that I realized oh this isn't a business
phenomenon it's a human phenomenon and
there's a pattern here that I think I've
been able put the pieces together I can
see that it's highly relevant for people
who are otherwise successful people
because the very nature of success is
that you will have this basic problem
you'll be stretched too thin
at work at home both and beyond you
you'll feel often busy but not
productive you will feel many different
pursuits hijacking your agenda each day
and and you just have more that you want
to do then you can do so that's in fact
a normal scenario for successful people
and so you know but but I felt like it
was an underserved problem because most
of the literature on success is how to
become successful in the first place but
for many many people
the real problem is what to do once you
are even if you don't feel very
successful you as soon as you have more
options and opportunity you know that
you can pursue you need a new way of
handling it than being a Saria where you
have no options at all so so this is
where I see the book you know came into
its own is is it's really one of the few
books connected to the subject of
success that's about what to do once you
are successful and underscore at least
my interpretation of that which is by
saying successful you don't necessarily
mean someone who's making a million
dollars a year or a company that's
generating a billion dollars in turnover
a year but in the simplest terms it's
someone who has more options than they
can execute on in their totality right
and if we think about power on some
level being having options
the there comes a point when you have
more options than you can possibly
metabolize and and use across the board
so then you start to have to winnow that
down and in that case this is where
principles of say essentialism are very
helpful and I thought that we might
explore a little bit one of the reframes
that I think is very clever and very
effective which relates to the endowment
effect could you talk and I can
certainly I have it right in front of me
if you'd like me to to jump in as a
reminder just in case yeah right it's a
reason apasa bility I fight I write very
long-winded books and I've done them
over a pretty long period of time so
every once in a while I get quoted and I
feel lost so if let me know I have
everything in front of me but the could
you talk about the endowment effect and
how you turn around questions people
might ask themselves about certain
things whether that is something they
own or an opportunity that gets
presented to them so I think this is
really important well let's use a
metaphor to get to the endowment effect
the the the you know our closet is a
pretty good metaphor for the for the
problem and what to do about it
so for a lot of people listening yeah
even as you say they don't feel as
incredibly successful financially
incredibly successful in all the things
in their life right they they probably
still have more things in their closet
than than they could they actually can
use usefully that it's a bit cluttered
maybe it's a lot more than a bit
cluttered I mean I talked to somebody
not so long ago and they said Greg my
closet that's it they said you've
identified the pain point they said I
have my closet organized by decade so
they organized it but it is sort of you
know they said you don't have a closet
you have a museum ma'am and you know
they have the 70s and the 80s let's
she's not using any of these things
you just has them and that's an
organized version of the problem which
is that we just have so much stuff now
that is true in the physical stuff it's
literally true in the closet but in the
closet of our lives it is equally true
now just staying with this metaphor for
a moment almost everybody has had a
moment where they say I've had enough
I'm going to organize my closet and they
you know they begin the process and they
take an item off the shelf off the floor
and they say you know I think it's time
to just get rid of this item and in the
moment of picking it up and reflecting
on it as if to give it away something
mysterious almost magical seems to
happen to many of us which is the moment
we're looking at we think well you know
yeah but I I you know I sure I want to
get rid of it right and I could use it
sometime in the future you know and
so-and-so gave it to me in there so I
and there's something is somehow in the
act of giving it away it's harder to
give it away than it was before we
picked it up to give it away so what's
going on and as it turns out there's a
heuristic a brain here a predisposition
that we have to all physical objects in
our life and also in fact all the the
opportunities that we have in our life -
and and it is this it's that we value
things more because we have them and
that means that's a good thing in
certain situations I mean that's why you
essentially yeah owning a home is
generally a good thing because people
look after the home better explains the
phenomenon why nobody in the history in
the whole world has washed their own
rental car you know it's a positive
phenomenon until and unless we over
value something that we really ought not
to have in the closet at all they ought
to go it is actually not useful to is
it's not valuable to us but we are over
valuing it and therefore keeping it so
it's over valuing because we own it or
it's endowed to us so in our life that
is an incredibly real problem we
we have them you know I'll give you an
illustration it's not in the book but
it's something that happened to me that
really hits a chord and it it happened
when I was staring at myself in the
mirror dressed from head to toe in a
stormtrooper outfit we're all good
epiphany start right and I look at
myself I realize two things I realize
that I have been thinking of this moment
in some small degree for 13 years this
is true I realize I'm standing there
staring I'm I'm in you know I'm in the
Halloween store yeah this is not a cheap
suit that I'm trying on and I remember
that this is goes back to like when I'm
10 years old and maybe Return of the
Jedi would come out of one of those Star
Wars movies and my older brother one of
my older brothers and said to me in
passing but with quite a lot of
enthusiasm wouldn't it be great to own
you know a stormtrooper just like from
the movies like really that the real
thing and somehow that got lodged in me
well that's an idea see that's something
you should pursue yeah that's what would
be so cool but all the brother thinks oh
it must be so and and somehow in the
back of my mind there it lives
unquestioned for 30 years and finally
I'm in the store yo thinking about where
the diplomas and in that moment I
actually have a sort of did have a
Eureka moment is there is no part of me
that wants this it stayed with me but I
don't it might forward your own self
does not need this one visits this is
ridiculous what I why you in this suit
right now and and and so I was able to
sort of separate myself from from at the
moment that's exactly what I'm
advocating here I'm saying that for a
lot of us we have a lot of became a
shortcut phrase my wife will said
sometimes to me now it is it is that a
stormtrooper that you're pursuing is
that strong stormtrooper opportunity
that you you used to think
was the thing but you're pursuing it
because you just sort of have it you
caught on to it you you feel a sense of
this endowment effect the sense of it's
my opportunites my thing it's my gods
and it's not-it's not serving me anymore
I think a lot of people have a lot of
stormtroopers in their life and so it's
not about the closet it's not about the
stormtrooper rather it's about the stuff
that really we need to get past and let
go so that we can pursue the right
things now not just the things that we
are pursuing because at one time we
wanted to pursue them or one time they
came into our life and it seems like
there are a number of ways to identify
these whether there's stormtroopers or
items opportunities that we are endowing
with a greater value because we have
them because we're either own them or
being presented with them right so you
could take let's just say that's sweater
from Aunt Mildred or whatever it is and
rather than asking how much do I value
this item you turn it around and ask if
I did not own this item how much would I
pay to obtain it right that turn around
seems really important to me or in the
case of opportunities and I'm quoting
directly from you here but you know how
will I feel if I miss out on this
opportunity instead of that if I did not
have this opportunity how much would I
be willing to sacrifice in order to
obtain it right that strikes me as a
very powerful reframe and is certainly
also I think it was Andy Grove at Intel
who also used this for you and there are
many other business examples but if we
were not already in this line of
business how much would be pay to pursue
it or would we pursue it in the first
place right as a way of pruning
activities and conserving resources so
they could be applied to the most
important things yes and the idea is to
trick your brain into putting it in the
position where you don't own the thing
where you don't have the opportunity so
you have to reflect on it afresh you
have to say okay starting now
do I want this thing now do I how hard
would I go after this now if I didn't
own it if I didn't have it and
helps us to evaluate things more without
this this inflation of the fact that we
own it the it is of course the amount of
it you co-created as I understand it a
class at Stanford GSB at the business
school yeah did that could you describe
that class and the the curriculum I know
nothing about this it was just mentioned
very briefly in passing in some of the
reading that I was doing in preparation
for this but could could you describe
the class and the intent and the
curriculum of that class yeah it was it
was co-created at the design school at
Stanford and the I mean the intent of it
was look could you you know but would
people be interested in really coming
together to design their life not just
using design principles which Design
Thinking has enormous application of
value to to our lives
but particularly the design thinking
with an essentialist lens so if you had
to come together and you had to design
your life and we we did it in design
pairs or even in design threes where you
would be designing for each other a life
around the most important thing the
essential things and and and if we
haven't made it clear it ought to be
made clear that this the this is what
essentialism is it's - its to figure out
what is essential it is to eliminate
what is not essential and it is to then
build a system that makes execution as
effortless as possible and that's
exactly what we were doing in that class
so people would come and they would work
together to to get greater clarity about
what really mattered versus what was
just good in their life you know what
those very few highest values are
highest value projects you know most
important contributions and and then
together to work
how can you start to trade off the
things that your of least value that
still play a role in your life that is
still the stormtroopers still still
taking up energy resources attention
that aren't really the right things and
and so this is this is what we were
doing we had a variety of exercises for
trying to get about could you walk us
through any of those exercises or
describe them because one of the one of
the topics I was going to get to of
course is how to answer the question you
know am i investing in the right
activities or how to determine that
because there are cases let's just say
in a sales organization where you have
very clear measurables very clear
deliverables and it's it's perhaps
rather straightforward that you have
just say solopreneurs or early-stage
entrepreneurs where they're wearing
seventeen different hats at a given time
and they they might actually have some
trouble identifying the answer to this
so could you walk us through any
exercises that you use with the students
yes I would love to do that and I'd love
to do it in a in a different way rather
than to talk about the abstract or even
just her to tell a story about someone
let's do it like if you're game I'll go
through an exercise that grew out of
those experiences but with you right now
you game let's do it okay it's this at
the risk of embarrassing myself I want
you and anybody who doesn't doesn't have
to overthink any of these questions this
is this is really simple but but it cuts
away all that the concepts you just gets
moving so okay so Tim just in your life
right now for real something think of
something tell me something that is
essential to you very important to you
that you feel you're under investing in
right now it's really matters but you
know you're not really putting the
resources you wished you were behind it
go okay I would say I'm investing in it
pretty well but probably not as much as
I should or feel that I that I should it
would be
experimenting with and researching
different modalities for addressing
psycho emotional trauma things that I
have not addressed in previous books so
the the the emotional component of life
that subconsciously very often drives so
many of our behaviors and patterns it
would be doing personal experiments
related to that and I've already done
that over the last four or five years
but really investing in organizing all
of that mm-hmm okay so so is clarifying
you sounded to me like there's a future
book here potentially potentially it's
it's something I didn't think I was
going to write for probably a few
decades but yes it's I've put it on a
closer burner it's not on the back
burner it's still on a burner but it's
it's been pushed from the back burner to
a front burner
yeah it's just a you you you you can see
that if you could identify the tools the
concrete ways of handling this kind of
deeper trauma I'm reading into this now
but that you've experienced that you
know other people have experienced that
that that could be incredibly valuable
to people because because it's actually
so much more Universal than is obvious
or it's not talked about a lot but it's
really universal challenge that we've
gone through traumas and we don't know
we don't have the skills and the tools
to know what to do with that that's
right so it is so it produces suffering
that's right that's right and in fact
many of the books that I've written
while I think very effective for helping
people to build businesses focus on
physical performance or improve physical
performance and appearance and so on can
those same objectives can be used as
salves or numbing agents to avoid the
root psychological or emotional traumas
that are causing self-destructive
behaviors
if that makes any sense so yeah yeah it
makes total it makes total sense and we
should go there for a moment because is
a friend of mine once said to me you
know success traps are often harder to
get out of them failure traps yeah
agree hands and so and so what you're
saying makes perfect sense to me that
that even a deliberate intense pursuit
of good objectives to be successful to
could could in fact be as you're saying
they could be just a form of being stuck
in a different more positive looking
coping mechanism yep
yeah and I should say also I'll let you
pick where we want to go that would be
one that would be one area I'm not
investing enough in potentially the
other would be rehabilitation of a
sacroiliac injury that I have in my hip
so be those are those are two options we
can go whichever direction you want I I
don't know yeah I kind of I'm looking to
you for it which which one's the most
important but I the first the first one
I think the most stay with that then
because because you know what what I'm
exploring a little with you here just to
be sort of transparent and the process
is why does it matter so much to you
right you said it's essentially you said
this thing matters and and we ought to
identify then really you know why and
maybe we're as far as we need to go on
that but I sensing you it's it's a
pretty deep why for you you know whether
we have words for or not it's like know
that you know I maybe it's like this
it's all of the books I've done before
are really preparing for this you know
that those have all given a platform you
know this is millions of people
literally right and and and you know and
well done you you built you built this
extraordinary platform to be out of
reach people make a difference and and
now what what what what is the what is
that the highest or deepest contribution
that can then be made and as you're
doing it I feel like there's a sort of
you know is that
quote that which is most personal is
most universal hmm and there's something
about that here which is which is okay
if we get really honest and and raw we
find that there's a lot of unresolved a
lot of unresolved trauma and now we're
riffing here a little bit beyond the
process but but I mean this is something
that's very like yeah this is important
to me the subject over on to yeah and it
so I can relate to it in this way one of
the things I've begun doing research
about is is intergenerational trauma and
how and how even if in our own lives we
go hi I think my life has been pretty
good in life has worked out and so on
what you find is that there can be that
there can be multiple generations of an
of unresolved issues that a manifest
wordlessly in our own lives because no
one talked about them so the
ramifications are real but we don't have
language that's the worst scenario to be
in yeah is to have is they have the
problem without any ability to even talk
about it to address it to to even know
that it's really there until we have
language things they're not even that
real okay or or the ability to feel that
something is off and an inability to
identify what it is even exactly in the
absence of words so the what I would put
together would be a from my perspective
or from my experience a comprehensive
description of my personal journey but
also the tools that I've found to be
most effective not only for myself but
for other people yeah so yes that's very
very important to me okay so so let me
ask you another question about this the
the which is what would what is success
for you and I don't mean success like
the okay the book is this or that you
know that's not even that's not even
necessarily the thing at this point it's
it's the yeah you could go down this
journey and conclude okay no this isn't
the right time for it and so on but but
what is your
daily amount of time that you would need
to invest in this for you to say to me I
now feel like I'm not under investing
anymore you know I I now feel so what's
the Delta between where you are right
now in a daily amount and where you say
no I'm not perfect it's not like I feel
amazing about how much time time and
something but I feel good about it's not
under invested anymore this this is a
really good question and I want to
explain why I struggle perhaps a bit to
answer it and I think this will also be
a struggle that applies to other people
this this is a this is a project where I
don't yet feel I have gathered enough
research to proceed to the writing and
synthesis phase even though I've
collected notes for almost five years
and so there's the question of am I
ready or am I not ready or am I simply
putting off the next step because I am
fearful of something I would say once I
get into synthesis phase and I am doing
a lot of experiments and have for the
last four or five years I would be
putting in four to five hours a day
minimum on this to feel fully vested I
can't I find it very difficult to put
together pros in any fashion or attempt
to put it together for more than three
or four hours a day so probably probably
yeah 3 to 3 to 5 hours per day but I
would be thinking about it all day every
day it would be running in the
background right yes Seinfeld was asked
recently how many hours did he spend
working on his the the recent one our
specially done fit for Netflix how long
how many hours did it take for him to do
it and he said he said he's the best
like asking God how long it takes for
him to grow an oak tree he's like but
all the time that's what he's doing all
the time he's just growing trees in the
world and everything is it he said that
that's what I'm doing it's not five
hours of 10 hours my whole
that's what I'm doing so I understand
that from what you're saying okay so
that that's interesting so so of the two
you just said two interesting things so
you said you said I don't know what it
is that's really keeping me back from
doing it you know so you don't there's
that there's a question mark here around
do I spend time on more research per day
yep or do I spend do I shift you know
you've got a gathering of research phase
and then there's a I'm gonna consciously
be applying it and writing about my
applications there's sort of a two-phase
process that you're following
overlapping but still distinct and to
answer my question about how much time
you need to spend you have to know which
phase you're in right right I would also
say if this is something that's useful
for that the the fear may be as simple
as [ __ ] it up because I've built this
book up in my mind for the last five
years is as almost certainly the most
important book I will have written today
and may ever write and there is a
there's a there's a very clear fear of
fumbling the ball when I've been given a
fantastic opportunity to do some good so
I think there's that as well there's a
fear of [ __ ] it up oh absolutely
i I could relate to that I just barely
begun in this very early process of
working on it and on a book and and and
my manager to myself for quite a while
with this has been don't write a rubbish
book yeah and and actually just recently
I think I say tearing that with my wife
and she's like yeah you might want to
come up with another mantra it's not
cute inside it's real fear I mean you
don't you and you when something's
important it way and and frankly when
from my point of view it's the easiest
thing in the world to write a bad book
pray that dad's dense like that's what
happens in fact and often
after a book that's been successful the
next books very hard for people to write
so so that alone is a fear but then
you've got this double whammy fear
because you're going it matters so much
I cannot get this wrong I cannot mess
this up yeah and and and and I think you
can sense but I'm pretty much in your
mouth but I think you can sense that
that may be just an obstacle that's
that's that's keeping you back but it
isn't really real like you're not gonna
write a rubbish book but you but you you
worry that you are and that worries
holding you back does that sound right
were your thoughts that sounds right to
me
it's helpful just to talk through
frankly so this is this is valuable for
me and your your mention of the the
mantra replacement that your wife
suggested made me think of something I
was told and I can't recall the
attribution so someone can find this
certainly but that worrying is like
praying for what you don't want so in a
sense that's brilliant I have the wrong
the antecedent framing that I have right
now is is preventing me from from taking
the the most essential next actions okay
so I can see III I accept and I agree
that it that's probably a phantom worry
like I'm not even if I wrote a book that
I felt was rubbish I also wouldn't
publish it right so you wouldn't publish
it there really isn't that fear isn't
real yeah what's the best mantra' for
you well the first thing that came to
mind was good now is better than perfect
later since there's a lot of suffering
in the world and not that I'm playing
Savior or anything like that but I've
experienced a lot of pain myself and
found things that work so there's an
argument to be made that the sort of
compounding of suffering over time would
mean that if I put out a book that is
80% of what it could be in ten years
it's still better than I put it out now
that may not be the the right mantra but
just to say enabling belief that could
be one or assumption
yeah yeah I like I like that um it I'm
one I'm curious about whether it's
perfectionism that is the barrier yes I
think that's absolutely think it is I
won't lie I cut short your multiple
choice second element is is is it is it
just the very subject itself yes that is
a form of perfectionism still isn't it
it's just it masses so much it can
really make a difference but if I don't
get it right what what if you don't get
it right what what happens then let's
let's say you didn't get it right what
what's what's the fear really what's the
fear really oh that I let people down
then I receive wide-spread criticism
because I didn't do enough due diligence
to cover all the bases and to test the
different modalities that I should part
of the big challenge in this particular
arena for me the subject matter which is
so broad is that unlike physical
performance where you have many
measurables unlike in the realm of
startups where you have key metrics and
so on which are measurables a lot of
this emotional terrain is very squishy
there's a lot of [ __ ] and a lot of
charlatans and a lot of I would say
imprecise thinking and faulty logic that
needs to be sifted through so it's it's
it's been a very challenging realm in
which to do testing and research if that
makes sense
oh yes we've got we're like in the germ
theory era yeah exactly
most notes formers yeah we're just just
you know it's a wild wild west in
comparison to what eventually we'll know
and we'll learn about the subject ok so
so so let's say let's say you you are
it's too bombastic way of saying it but
let's say you've kind of been a little
bit hiding behind this concern this this
fear and and and we're gonna now shift
towards phase two of the project right
where it's where okay I don't have it
all of course I don't have it all there
is no such thing as that you know eighty
percent is going to be good enough my
manager at 80 percent if it's 80 percent
good I'm gonna be able to move forward
so let's say you do move to the second
thing you said you identify three to
five hours is that additional three to
five hours of from where you've been
before is that you spending some time on
a now so now you have to add another two
hours what what's the I'm spending the
way I've been working on it and my
apologies for folks if this is if this
is does not immediately seemingly apply
to what you're doing but hopefully this
is helpful just to hear people or to
hear the two of us work through this
process wise the research phase for me
is very chunky if that makes sense
it's two weeks of 24/7 and then four
weeks of trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] just happened and it's it's not a
daily slow and steady process whereas
the if I were to say enough is enough
Tim you could always do more research
this is a defense mechanism you're using
to put off starting the composition of
the book start the composition of the
book then I would get it into a phase
where I'm looking at that three to five
hours a day on a regular consistent
basis so I would say I'm effectively
starting at zero because I'm in Phase
one where for instance ending about a
week ago I was two weeks off the grid
doing pure experimentation and research
and gathering notes so I have that but
then for the last week I have
effectively spent zero time on it
because I am in the down the downshifted
phase mm-hm
without an active experiment okay so so
before we can move on this is all
everything
we've done is really covering the first
phase they're not equally they're not
equal phases but phase one of applying
essentialism is what is essential and
that includes why does it matter what
does success look like and what's the
the thing you want to shift to and so on
so it's it's you know and and I always
want to emphasize this small side point
which is that sometimes when people even
when they read essentialism or certainly
if they've record about just the
peripheral level they think I've written
a book about sort of saying no and that
is part of it but I didn't write a book
called you know called no ism it's it's
about essentialism and so that's why the
the thrust of this conversation has to
be there because we've got to get clear
what's essential what do we actually
need to make a change if that's in that
that is highly important to us and
that's what gives drive to everything
else so just before moving on to the
trade off phase I think I can identify
my my core question before with the
multiple choice I don't feel like I gave
the multiple choice properly it's it is
the primary thing the the perfectionism
or is the primary thing just a personal
pain not not of writing a book that's
its own kind of pain heavy lifting right
for sure there's that but there's just
this particular subject the very nature
of it is riskier you know riskier to put
it out there riskier to be vulnerable
riskier to to explore these things that
kind of a level riskier to be criticized
when it's something that's so personally
so personally vulnerable I go there's a
very fair question I think it's I think
it's perfectionism
I've except spent the last handful of
years coming to terms with the risks
inherent in writing a book like this and
the inescapable barrage of criticism
that I will get and so I'm really trying
to in gathering the notes focus on or
have the base assumption that it's not
how many people don't get it that
matters it's how many people do get it
and yeah focusing I mean there are and I
heard recently in this actually a
documentary which is very entertaining
called the price of everything
paraphrasing here but there are three
categories of people those who see those
who can see when shown and those who
will never see and I'm really in the
context of a book like this trying to
focus on the first two categories so
I've accepted the the risks I think come
to terms with most of them it's it's
perfectionism I think yes that is that
is the hurdle I'm not clearing at the
moment yeah at least one yeah and it
just I mean I just still want to be on
this just for a moment I mean I I just
want to support you in the process I
mean that this the idea of a kind of
tools the Titans but applied to this
pain point
mmm-hmm just seems totally relevant
it just seems you know as anxiety has
become the number one you know diagnosed
condition
beating out depression now right does it
is there's stuff going on and there's
stuff going on there's more traumas
going on in a variety of ways I think
that's fair to say but also there's more
openness to talking about traumas so all
these backlog of things not discuss to
suddenly be you know being able to be
discussed and and there's just so much
going on in the cloud of noise out there
in social media and a variety of ways
you know that that I think people feel
unsettled inside and we've always known
that there were things out there that
could hurt as writers that we had the
Cold War we had there's always risks in
the world but recently I feel like the
risks feel more within people than they
used to and so I just think it's so
relevant and and and I think I think the
way that you would approach in you know
there's there are obviously people that
will need it just the way you do it
weaknesses and all you know yeah what's
and all that there so I
okay so that's it there's the case one
okay so so so let's let's move down to
Phase two which is what what are you
willing to give up to do this you know
what let me ask it slightly differently
which is what is something non-essential
that you're over investing in currently
yeah that's a great question
I've already categorically in the last
six months cut out certain things say
certainly any type of book blurbs which
necessitate reading books those are all
gone yeah speaking engagements all gone
with very rare exception unless they
happen to be within a 15 minute walk of
where I live which doesn't doesn't
happen very often and so is just like
classic there's ever a your email
bounce-back has a word attachment to it
am I making this up I think this is what
I seem to recall it might it might it is
evolved over time but it's it's very
it's very clear on the things that I do
not do one after another after another
like none of this stuff you ever eaten
had to be for any of this stuff there is
no point and I do I do when possible try
to point people to other helpful
resources would you which for whatever
for whatever reason people really don't
want to read they want me to regurgitate
it in a half-assed manner to them one on
one rather than just pointing to them to
resource but that's a whole separate
conversation so there are there are
things that have categorically decided
to say no to because I do not do
moderation well with those those items
right I don't do moderation well nobody
does moderation well that's my is my
opinion about this Soviet people don't
do moderation well I decided go out
sugar a year ago and almost a year ago
New Year's Eve talking to somebody I've
been thinking about doing it for a while
they've been on sugar for 12 years and
I'm like okay you know 12 years I can do
a year I'm going to make this decision
if I've gone 95 percent off
oh no I'm out before I begin
everything's an exception well that's
you know that's amazing cake I've gotta
eat that I mean that's oh this is a
holiday I'm gonna eat that it's the
weekend I'm going how's my wife I got it
now she's into that guy everything's an
exception so I think there's a variety
of things in life that it's a much much
easier to go a hundred percent than it
is to go 95 percent because what you're
doing is you're taking out the decision
process it's done we are not doing sugar
now I don't have to think every time and
by the way there's crazy amounts of
sugar in this world yeah I don't have to
think about it every time the decisions
already made so anyway I guess it's oh
there's a lot of things you've cut out
what not so I have one so the first I
want to just mention that one of the one
of the concepts in essentials and that I
really appreciated is trying to find the
one decision that removes a thousand
decisions such as the the elimination of
sugar that you mentioned as just one
example I will tell you where I struggle
and I think I'm better than maybe
average Joe or Jane at saying no to
things I'm quite good but one of the
great ironies of writing a book called
say essentialism or the 4-hour workweek
is that if those concepts hit and the
books do well you suddenly have a flood
a torrent of inbound requests and all
sorts of new categories of things to
contend with and I find myself
struggling to say no to people who
probably land on the spectrum of good
acquaintances to reasonably good friend
who asked for help with various things
and there are certain things that I feel
very comfortable saying no to like the
book blurbs but I have hundreds of
requests those aren't all from friends
but dozens certainly for promotion of
their books on social it's usually book
related because people want their books
to sell being on the podcast you name it
and I have I feel like friends who do
not fully think of the ramifications of
their request often times when it's
last-minute where they wouldn't ever go
to the New York Times the day before
they have something come out and ask for
everything to be reshuffled for their
benefit that is what ends up happening
to me on a fairly regular basis so I
think I allocate too much time to trying
to explain myself to those people or
placate those people in some way and I
would love to hear your thoughts on best
practices or heuristics related to that
specifically because I don't view myself
as a people pleaser but nonetheless with
this particular subset of people I do
find it really challenging and there are
times when people I would like to
maintain a good relationship with who
come to me last-minute for help that I
cannot deliver without massively
inconveniencing my entire team and
reshuffling get very pissed in a way or
they take it very personally and maybe
that's okay I think I tend to think that
it is and I'm going a little long here
but it's I think a challenge that a lot
of people face what are your thoughts
well let's let's just agree on the
problem first of all because as a CEO
friend of mine once told me he said is
that I take every time and resource
estimate that's given to me now and I
multiply it by PI so he's saying I
thought he was exaggerating at first but
he's saying he's saying that people so
massively underestimate everything and
there is another heuristic for this
right it's called the planning fallacy
the final fallacy is saying these things
take we as humans underestimate almost
all the time how long things will take
and we do that even with things we have
done ourselves before driving from point
A to point B takes us 15 minutes but if
we
in the middle of writing an email we
will convince ourselves we can do it in
five minutes this time well get there
all green lights everything's gonna work
somehow it'll be done in five minutes of
course we do it doesn't take that long
it takes 50 minutes so we're late for
the meeting right but we want Connor
selves into it what you're describing I
think as two pieces to it the first is
this piece and the second is the
relationship impact of how to handle
this but what you're describing is a
problem where somebody is really under
estimating what their request is they're
saying in their head they're going this
is a two-minute favor Tim it's not hard
all you have to do is put out a tweet
how hard can it be or whatever and so in
their head they're asked is very small
but the reality is that their ask is
much bigger right they don't link them
they also don't think about the
reputational risk or anything like that
of endorsing something that I don't have
time to read a for instance well that's
exactly so you know so so I think that
there is something around this again
before we get to the relationship impact
of and maybe it's maybe you already did
it but of actually creating one page
you've got the email bounce-back
document having a page that says look
this is the real cost the total cost of
ownership of me saying yes to this so so
that and maybe because even once it's
created it could be used in a variety of
ways one is reactively right when the
request comes in okay I needed to read
this first I need to understand but
maybe there's a proactive approach which
is like look this is I'm just putting
this out there this is what this
actually costs because even what you
just said reputational costs not that
people aren't thinking about that you
know they're just thinking about getting
their thing achieved and and so being
able to try and calculate all of that
the total cost of ownership I mean
that's what you have to do with the
planning fallacy is we have to consider
the total cost so that we don't start
projects so we don't complete in fact
there's a New York Times just ran a
piece about exactly this that I'm aware
of because of because it's quoting
essentialism you know in in trying to
address the problem but of
all these projects can start we don't
finish this is just a version of that
problem that they're coming they're not
sure they're not being the maybe are
being thoughtless maybe they don't think
they're being thoughtless they just
think it's not a big deal for you and
they don't understand the full range of
impact so I think writing this out live
almost like it's a recipe this is the
cost and in that I think in the helpful
side of it you could say so in the
future if you want to be considered this
is the process you would need to go
through you know so that so again what's
what's happening is that you've got to
help other people's problems be their
problem right and and there's a story I
came across with a book that I really
like on this this principle which is I
think it's a true story
I said quite remember now but it's a dr.
cloud he's talking about meeting with a
couple or husband why their parents and
they come to see him and they say they
say look you know our son we have so
many problems with our son and you know
he says I'm drugs he's he's drinking all
the time it's living back at home with
us now I mean he's just not got a job
everything is just such a mess for this
is so concerning he says okay well I
understand where is he though where you
have an appointment here to deal with
this where is your son they said they
said well you know he's he doesn't
really see that he has a problem and and
and that's a person's well I think I
think he's right and they're shocked at
that what do you mean that he's right
you know just described all the problems
he said no he says he says listen he
says if if you look outside your window
in the morning and your sprinkler head
on your lawn is faulty and it's spraying
on your neighbor's grass and your
neighbor's grass is green and your grass
is dying who has the problem you've got
the problem right because your grass is
dying your neighbor doesn't have a
problem their grass is fine either your
son doesn't have a problem because he's
comfortable at home with you he has to
do whatever
she's looked after life is fine he
doesn't have a problem you have a
problem and your job now is to help your
son to have a problem your son have his
problem in a well-intended you'd be well
intended to truck but you've got it all
wrong you've got to let him own it if he
doesn't have a problem if he if
everything's taken care of for him he
can't move forward he can't get better
and and so now obviously it's a bit
strong to use that example with the
example that you've you've led this
conversation with but but it is a
similar principle is that there has to
be a boundary and there has to be an
education of going you know you've made
this from my problem right now let me
just lay this out so that you can own
the problem so in the future we can do
this
perhaps in a better way yeah it's it
makes perfect sense I I was told
something not not too terribly long ago
maybe two years ago it's just along the
lines of a line you could use with such
people although you'd probably have to
dress it up a little bit which is you
know your lack of planning does not
constitute my emergency right right and
which is just I suppose in theory makes
a lot of sense but it sometimes falls by
the wayside and practice due to fear of
social repercussions which we can get to
and in a second I mean I've had some
awful experiences and I don't to turn
this into a 100 percent Tim Ferriss
therapy session but just so people know
for those people out there who may be
like oh yeah that Tim Ferriss you never
agreed to X or whatever it is I've had
instances where journalists from
mainstream publications have reached out
for book blurbs or help with their own
projects I have Paul very politely
declined because I've been unable to
help them in the capacity they required
and they've gone on to write like hit
pieces or hatchet pieces or slammed
pieces about me out of spite and it's
like that kind of [ __ ] happens so I
think I'm a little once bitten twice shy
from a lot of those experiences but
ultimately does any of that prevent me
from doing the
essential project that we discussed not
really so well that well that that right
there is of course is is exactly the
point if you know one can say let's take
the let's take the the opposite argument
for a moment and and I'll just play
non-essential astir the conversation
which is yes Tim you're getting it wrong
you're thinking about yourself too much
and you every single request that
someone from from from media or any
friend or any acquaintance that anything
that they want from you you should be
saying yes there's what you know you got
helped by lots of people therefore
you're under total obligation to do it
for everybody else and and and you got
this wrong so is that argument right is
it really right it could be right is it
right it's it's I don't think it's right
and even if it were right it's not
sustainable right it can't be right or
will not continue it cannot continue
right so what you just said which is
awesome is like is like well it's
correct other than it's impossible yeah
right you helped us to to understand the
basic foundational error with
non-essential ISM like the problem with
non-essential ISM is that it happens it
was the only from happens to be a lie
it's just got that inconvenience
associated with it you you can't
actually do everything you can't
actually get this next book that we've
just identified what it is why it
matters deeply why it matters launched
living and and out into the universe and
also do everything that people think is
reasonable for you to do you cannot do
both of those things
as soon as you come to terms with that
you say okay well good okay that's not a
solution I can have that actually isn't
it's not you say not sustainable that
means it can't be done you can pretend
you can be doing it for a little while
and then the book doesn't get written so
all those people that the ones that
aren't probably asking anything from you
but they're still in pain and you could
still do something to be useful to them
provide them some helpful insights that
you've gained you know you can do that
or you can you can keep helping the
people that are asking for the things
that that really you know disrupts that
whole process so which do you want you
know which problem Tim do you want
yeah the former the former right mm-hmm
okay now you're right it doesn't make
the problem go away that you suddenly
feel bad and there could be other hit
jobs and there could be other
misunderstandings increases and that's
true now so what we do is separate the
decision from the relationship you've
got to think of the decisions in two
separate buckets we've just done that
you know you've made the decision you
understand the decision and then of
course you say well there is still gonna
be relationship impact and that is true
and I don't think you should pretend
that that isn't true you know somehow in
some area fairy essentialist land oh you
can edit you know because that would be
violating the whole idea which is that
essentialists embrace the reality of
trade-offs of course there are
trade-offs you know of course there will
be people that are frustrated right
there they want the peace but just think
about think about you know think about
somebody Oprah how many requests are
going that she can't possibly ask how
many people send her books can you
imagine how many books were being sent
to Oprah and the height of her the the
Oprah Show and everything I mean it's
insane you're number of well warehouses
for had to be warehouses for going that
way and she had to get somehow we
assumed that she appeared to to be to
get to a level of peace we don't look
this is no way I can even touch any of
that stuff I've got to find to be truer
to this to this voice within me
clarity about what my mission is and my
essential mission and not all of this
other stuff it's not being unhelpful to
the world for you to say no to something
that's less important is not being
unhelpful or selfish in the world today
I don't buy that your application is to
this to the highest point of
contribution you can make and but what I
think happens a lot is that people get
caught up in the idea that can I do this
thing and they it's like they they
pretend there's nothing left nothing
else going on in their life the request
comes in and they go can I do this
well yes I can do this I know how to do
is I can make this happen
and and and that's not life that's non
essentialist junk that's just rubbish
the question is if I do this thing what
doesn't get done what else gets pushed
out now I'm not saying don't be help the
people to come requesting things that
can be absolutely ways of helping people
I want to help people but but if it's at
the cost of something that's actually
more important that makes a higher
contribution we have a obligation not to
do it now there's one more piece here
which is important which is that you
don't want to hurt these relationships
and that's where the concern really
comes from so the question is is how can
you deal with this in a way that
minimizes the damage to you through some
media outlet stuff doing some hit peace
or help people to understand the context
behind it and I think that still comes
back to at least for yourself writing
this all out you know this is what I am
trying to do and why it matters I mean
in a way it's having the conversation
we've just had mm-hmm but written out so
that it can be expressed again and again
and again the why behind this answer the
why it's the thing that we miss out on
so let's in fact move to step three so
step one was what is essential step two
is what is non-essential in step three
is how do you create a system that makes
executing what's essential as effortless
as possible and it's a perfect way to
get there at this point because because
having this this written out document
and
how you'll use it is not sure yet about
that in my own head but if you have it
clearly written out this is what I'm
doing this is why this is the cost of
disrupting that this is what it does
this is who will lose out if I don't
stay focused on this now all of that
becomes like a core a communication core
for yourself at a pivot but place to
pivot to when the request comes in you
know I maybe I can change it you know
everything today to make that possible
and you go hold on let's go back to the
document my system was was away from
look a while a couple of weeks and and
the amount of damage I managed to do in
those couple of weeks we predicted us
you know the number of things I managed
to commit to pay attention but actually
she was gone for a month I'm remembering
now it's for a honeymoon and and when
she she comes back and I I was very
positive
I wasn't saying I've messed everything
up I said let me tell you all the things
that happened in the month you've gone
and it was just had a little silence at
the end of it all because she's like if
she didn't say it but this is this is
what's in the silence it's like you know
what's wrong with you
you know how are you thinking that you
can take on all of those projects and
all of those ideas like that's you you
aren't you aren't thinking fully about
the cost of doing all those things that
she was dead right and what grew out of
that is we came up with three rules of
things that I would and wouldn't do and
I'll give one of the rules was no
personalization and ending any
personalization so if I'm if I'm doing
keynotes workshops whatever I'll listen
I'll understand what the you know what
the company or the client at the
conference needs but but I'm not going
to redo rethink re-change I'm not
changing the slide and I'll change it
that you know the subtle things you can
do in the moment but I'm not redoing
stuff because if you refuse personalize
everything as I as I want to do you it's
like you're rewriting a book every time
I mean you have to rethink everything
and that was one rule and we had to of
the world there are those are so helpful
and when I'm
you willing to share the other two rules
I'm trying to I should I should know
what they are right if I say those three
rules and they were really useful to me
if they come up they come up you can
also walk wait for them to surface yeah
so actually one was one was don't over
over over correct based on based on a
negative feedback and that's a little
more volatile to share that one but I
think everybody suffers with that vets
that's why you know which is most
persons most universal I you know so
some so we do an event do a keynote
conference gets good feedback one of the
people you know in the comments says X
and I think Jesus elute right that isn't
that is a valid criticism let's change
it let's redo how we're doing this to
address that concern it's the same sort
of thing it's overreacting to it and
frankly when you overreact to this kind
of feedback you really cause a problem
for other people giving feedback and I
in hindsight can see how that's been in
my life right somebody who's trying to
be helpful they're trying to be honest
they're giving the feedback and I'm
multiplying the effect of it and then it
so that was number two and I think
number three might have been something
like you know it was like either no new
projects like beyond what we'd
identified like we very identified a
couple of really big things I want to go
after it was like no no no new projects
outside of that it might have been it
might have been specifically no workshop
business which is there's always a
demand for it with essentialism there's
always been interest in it I always feel
an obligation because one there's a need
people are interested and to you know
just just I think there's a full
business here and it could it could
easily be or have been successful
business and those things have keep
pulling me into it and and I just might
whenever I start working on it I'm like
you know you see those kids in a
Superman you see a kid
on the floor not throwing a tantrum they
just lying on the floor like legs spread
out I'm spread out just like that they
have no energy to even get up off the
floor this is this is how much passion
they feel too for being in the
supermarket on this day just like
nothing here is interesting not one part
of me wants to be getting up and doing
this that's how I feel in that business
say that in one way or another so many
times okay should do I know I should do
this okay let's do it we make it happen
and finally she's just like look there's
no part of you that wants to do this why
are you doing this it's so weak most I
think those are the truth we got there
so instead of storm trooper you could
use floor angel as a shorthand for that
we're doing floor angels what you can of
building a system for you and I don't
want to I don't want a short changes too
much we needed a little more which is
sure you've identified now something
that you is essential to you you've
identified something that's
non-essential but all quit for you that
that's risky for you that you you could
give up so there's a trade-off now so we
have an essential trade-off and but
that's not enough because as soon as you
know we've finished this conversation
all of those dynamics that have been
there before still are there there is a
system in place that keeps you away from
getting on with this next book it keeps
you saying yes to requests and feeling
really fearful about about pushing back
we've identified one thing so far you
can do to build a system which is
writing this all out so that you have it
there so that you can either say in
person or put in email or express
clearly the why in of why this cannot
simply be an easy yes why this is a
costly yes and and this makes me just
think for a moment just about this
simple idea which is that too
every request whether there are quest
comes from somebody else or from within
ourselves which is where a lot of the
non-essential stuff comes from there's
only three options right you can say yes
you can say no or you can negotiate and
that's it and and I think what happens
is that people default yes because
they're so fearful of a rude no and its
effects and so they forget that there is
a negotiate part of this there is a
educate part of this and that's what I
think this is this document can help
with is is reminding yourself at Edo
getting yourself clear and then you can
educate other people too because they
just don't know they don't understand
what their request really means and what
the cost really is so so that's one
thing but there's got to be more and we
ought to do something else that will
actually help you make the shift let me
just ask one more time do you want to
make this shift
do you want to make this trade-off yes I
do okay so so what would help do it I
mean you've got masses and ideas
yourself already of hats and tools and
tricks to be able to help people to
execute when they otherwise wouldn't so
you could definitely help to co.design
this right that's how we began right the
design school at Stanford to help
actually design a system that's weighted
in your favor and we know when we'll get
there we'll know when we've achieved it
because on a day you don't want to make
the trade-off you'll still make it right
on a day that you don't want to make the
trade-offs you'll still make it that's
when you've got a system working on your
side yeah which is I should just also
note for people listening applies to
diet applies to exercise applies to just
about anything where a system can be
designed that is weighted in your favor
in such a way that it's it's unlikely to
fail right so one question / topic that
would be very helpful just to hear you
talk about I've thought about it quite a
lot but I'd love to hear your thoughts
and it'll give me also an excuse to read
something from your book that I that I
enjoy is
determining what a fair well reasoned
polite decline looks like and
recognizing that I only have control
over the delivery of that message not
how people emotionally respond to it and
really just leaving it at that like I
have delivered my message in a fair
even-handed manner and it's up to the
recipient as to how they want to respond
and if they if they over react in some
negative way that is their problem not
my problem and I bring it up on a meta
level I just want to mention one line
that I highlighted in your book actually
I mentioned to the first is make your
peace with the fact that saying no often
requires trading popularity for respect
and I'll just read this part here yes
saying no respectfully reasonably in
gracefully can come in a short-term
social cost but part of living the way
of the essentialist is realizing respect
is far more valuable than popularity in
the long run this gives me an excuse to
just read I don't think I would use this
exact text but Peter Drucker who is one
of my favorite authors his extremely
boring lis titled book the effective
executive is he remains one of my my my
repeat reads but his response and you
may have to help me with the last name
here but I think it's is it check sent
me hi is that the professor is replying
to you but he's replying to a request
and his polite decline goes as follows
quote I am greatly honored and flattered
by your kind letter in February 14th for
I've admired you in your work for many
years and I've learned much from it but
my dear professor C I'll just abbreviate
I'm afraid I have to disappoint you I
could not possibly answer your questions
I am told I am creative I don't know
what that means I just keep plotting I
hope you will not think me presumptuous
or rude if I say that one of the secrets
of productivity
whereas I do not believe in creativity
is to have a very big all caps very big
waste paper basket to take care of all
all caps invitations such as yours
productivity in my experience consists
of not all caps doing anything that
helps the work
people but to spend all one's time on
the work and the good Lord has fitted
one to do and to do it well end quote
that's that's very clear and very direct
ha do you have any suggestions for
templates or favorite ways of saying no
to requests from people you know that
you simply cannot or do not want to
comply with let's just pause for a
second on that story how do we have the
text why do we know that that's how he
responded well we know because we know
because it got published in the book on
creativity positively saying this is one
of the keys to creativity is you know I
reached out to him and he showed me this
and I learned something in the process
which is that highly creative people are
willing to block out space to do the
work that they are built to do and want
to do and aren't just doing everything
that everybody else is doing what
everybody asks of them so it what it
helps us to identify is that there is
such a situation as being able to push
back say no and there to be a positive
result come from it you know I liked you
I liked your email bounce back this was
positive to me I learned things from it
myself this is you know there is such a
thing and often with such novices at no
we just are so fearful of it we don't
learn how to do it and we don't do it so
we just assume that bad things are going
to come sometimes they do but I think
that we are we have to do like reverse
pilots sometimes where we try not doing
something and saying no to something or
just not doing it at all and seeing what
the effects are and learning from it in
our way you know in terms of a template
I've explored lots of templates and lots
of things as an example that came up
recently I really liked which is the
illustrates one way to do this is from
is from Warren Buffett Warren Buffett
right respected yes right quoted all the
time
arguably the most
did investor ever you know he's
constructed a system in his life that
allows him to communicate and give back
to people you know through his through
his annual conference for example but
that doesn't mean that he's saying yes
that every quest along the way so in
fact there's an interesting story Tony
Robbins tells a story in his in his book
on finance about Warren Buffett in which
he basically failed to get Warren
Buffett to ever be interviewed for his
book he's getting all the big top
investors that he's priding himself from
being able to access these people and
he's he's using all of those named
people and those relationships excuse me
to go after warren buffett to keep
tapping him for an interview and and and
still he's not getting anything so then
they're at some meteor event together
they're about to you know one's bet he's
leaving and tell he's going on to be
interviewed and he catches him for
saying he says oh i'm doing this book
and so-and-so is reaching out to you and
i'd love to have you in this and and his
response was was uh you know i just
don't i think i just said everything i
could say on that subject I just don't
think there's you know there's anything
else I could I could I could add to
what's what's already out there well
that's that's his polite though and the
people that are best that I don't think
are saying no and I don't even think
they have to be as Peter Drucker was
kind of I mean a particularly explicit
necessary either I think you could just
be very quiet
happily gently you know I'm I just don't
think I could add anything to that
projects a thanks for thinking of me I
just don't think I'm I'd be the right
person for that I just think you know
I've done everything I can do on that
and and it's so important I mean Peter
Drucker's not director and Warren
Buffett I cannot find the original
citation of this that it's him but he's
quoted as having said that the
difference between successful people and
very successful people is that very
successful people say no to almost
everything mm-hmm and that's what he's
doing so I think what I'm trying to say
sometimes you can simply say no I mean
it it does depend on the relationship
and the request
but also I think sometimes it's just the
best no is a yes it's saying it's saying
look yes I can I can do you know I'm
doing this so I just couldn't do
anything beyond this you know I I'm your
request to be interviewed with something
hi you know I've I'm working on this
book this this really important project
it's high-risk for me I think it can
make a huge difference but it's
consuming all of my energies and
creativity right now to do this right
and I just can't get this wrong that's
that's that's you know that's what I've
that's what I can do I think it's it's
starting with the yes in some ways I
think the best knows are really really
saying the yes that we're committed to
saying what we're what we're doing and
you're right sometimes people they'll
react badly but that if we've been
respectful if we've been thoughtful if
we've been useful within the parameters
that we've identified for example if you
can actually do a favor for someone in
five minutes if you really have a system
that allows it to be five minutes fine
five minute favor I'm a big I can be a
believer in that discipline giving I'm a
believer in that but if within that
context you've made if then somebody is
upset takes the victim approach is
basically throwing a tantrum yeah that's
that's no fun for anybody but that's not
good enough reason to have said yes to
it as every great leader who's ever
dealt with and every great parent has
dealt with almost of the daily basis
every great parent is dealing with a
situation where a child wants something
and they may throw some sort of tension
if it is not a major tantrum because
they didn't get the thing they wanted of
course and we just have to be adults
about it and mature about it and and
recognize yeah you know I'm gonna keep
everybody happy all the time what's a
calm definitely you you have is it for
kids Yeah right so not not very
essentially something but you've had a
fair amount of practice
with the the tantrum mitigating or at
least accepting of those possible
consequences I'd love to chat for a
second if if we if we can and this just
gives me an option to to read also
something that that's stuck with me from
your book which was and I'll just read
the excerpts so this is a case study or
a story of a gentleman named Jeff GE o
FF and talks about his progressive
burnout effectively but he he ultimately
quote paid a high price to learn a
simple yet essential lesson and that is
protect the asset and then I I thought
this was worth mentioning for people who
are type-a personalities achievers who
are very good at getting things done or
pride themselves on that and the quote
is as follows in the many hours Jeff
spent resting he came to see an
interesting paradox resting after he
burned out interesting paradox in his
addiction to achievement for type-a
personality it is not hard to push
oneself hard pushing oneself to the
limit is easy the real challenge for the
person who thrives on challenges is not
to work hard he explains to any
overachievers quote if you think you are
so tough you can do anything I have a
challenge for you if you really want to
do something hard say no to an
opportunity so you can take a nap and I
thought this might be a good place to
explore the quarterly off-site which I
don't recall is being explored very much
in the book but I've heard it mentioned
in some interviews that you've done
could you perhaps elaborate on what the
personal quarterly off-site is it's it's
creating space for you to actually think
long term about what really matters in
the great you know in the greater scheme
of things I mean it's the same as any
executive team they have a quarterly
off-site and annual off-site why do they
do it because they know if they don't
they're going to get buried in reacting
to to the proximate issues instead of
seeing strategically where they want to
be
headed and what trade-offs they need to
make in order to get there and if it's
just the same for it's the same for at
the individual level we my wife and I
started doing the quarterly off sites
two or three years ago and and that that
in fact in fact one of the things I did
to try and describe the system to make
sure we followed through is I did it
where we had a few people come together
and and I was sort of leading the the
process but but underneath one of the
important intents of it was so that Ana
and I could actually have a full day
once every quarter you know way from
everything else and to think about the
the long-term calls and and out of that
process for us and what what are you
doing on that in that process you you're
saying okay what's happened over the
last you know that big picture you could
say okay what's happened to my life
well what's the long-term perspective
here we're about where where am i where
whatever bid what's been going on you
see you're trying to get a clear view of
of your life what's been going on with
it and then you say okay going forward
long-term perspective what what would I
like to be achieved
what what what feels important again
it's not just success says it's not just
goal setting you know set the wrong
goals
it's what's essential to me what it
feels like my mission to pursue and and
I remember in that very first official
session that we did and as she was going
through the process had identified a
couple of things that were really
important and I could tell they were
they had been within her but they just
have came to us the surface one of them
one of them was a Hello might sound
funny to people but but it was like
horses horses right that's a weird thing
to say isn't there horses there's
nothing we expect me to say she said I
just had this vision of having a place
with horses and it's not necessarily
even that we were in the horses it
wasn't even necessarily that
and we don't have any horse background
it's not a horse people I mean nothing
like that but but it was a sense of if
we if we were to achieve what that means
our children would grow up in a certain
kind of environment it was like a symbol
of a certain type of childhood and our
children were at the time was sort of in
in the golden years which means which
means the years before they're driving
and after they're out of diapers and so
it's like a magical period because you
can do things you can make memories
together you can do it and we weren't
living in a place at the time we were in
the middle of Silicon Valley which is
terrific in lots of ways but it's not
it's not you know you're not gonna end
up with horses right you have to think
differently and that single insight in
that core to the off-site shifted a
whole sense of intent and we realized if
we want to do this while our children
are still in this golden years we're
gonna have to move sooner rather than
later to be able to achieve this dream
otherwise we're going to achieve it
after at least the Elvis is out of the
house and then well as the point and so
it was an insight a strategic insight
that has had profound influence on a you
know it's a one decision that makes a
thousand there's a whole series of
things we had to do to put in process to
be prepared to organize it to find such
a place and so on and it took a while to
do it but it took a couple of years
maybe maybe as much as that and and and
out now we live in a community that
you're required to have space for horse
that you don't have to have them but you
have to have space for them and and that
single criteria again makes a lot of
other influences change right you're
going to be around a lot of nature
you're going to be even the kind of
people in some ways that you're around a
certain certain value system that they
care about all those kinds of things
and so and so that's the that's sort of
a personal example of why to hold
personal quarterly off sites it shifts
whole direction you're going in it gives
you it tilts and bends your your you
know your narrative as you go forward do
you have any recommendations for other
format best practices or any best
practices for personal offsites is that
it is it an afternoon is it a day is it
two days is it in your living room is it
off-site okay here's what I think I
think I think it's off-site it's in
nature or thereabout you know it's it's
somewhere that's that's quiet
uninterrupted I know if some people I've
never done this but I know some if
someone who has a second phone and their
second phone is a it's like one of these
little credit card sized phones and
there's only two people in the world
that have the number to this phone and
so when they go it means they can be
reached for emergency but that's it and
so they are just gone so that they can
have an under trip to space which is
very hard to have these days so you want
to be in an uninterrupted environment
you want to not have tags that email and
all of that available
you know III recommend you either to on
your own or maybe with one other person
you know a design partner that you can
you can really go through the process I
think that the longer the perspective is
the better you know the one I was
referring to we actually started prior
to our life you know it's back to those
who started great-grandparents in fact
great-grandparents parents your own life
and then going forward to the end of
your life to your kids grandkids
great-grandchildren or if you have
children it's just the people that you
would influence generations from now and
it's that kind of huge vision that kind
of level of perspective that helps to to
draw up within you an unexpected insight
something that you already know but
somehow is being buried because you're
you're thinking about life in in in just
sort of reactive ways what questions do
you ask related to you or might you ask
related to say your grandparents or
great-grandparents it portion of the
of the session things that include well
first of all write down anything you
know about them it won't take long
it's its own kind of lesson actually
what what what do you know about them
most people I think less than 5% of
people not scientifically but based on
thousands of people many thousands
people I've asked this question to now
cannot name the first and last names of
each of their great-grandparents right
eight great-grandparents they cannot
name the first and last name of all
eight we cannot even name the the first
and last names of the people that male
is everything we I it's extraordinary
it's its own lesson then we they that's
where where we live at the country we
live the the language we speak that
everything was in with either determined
by them or largely influenced by these
people we don't even know their names
amazing but we know something about them
if we know anything about we should
gather it what has lasted what decisions
have they made that still affect us even
if we don't know anything about them
what to see you know they we know know
their names we know that well they move
to this country they move to this place
they did anything that we know they've
impacted us so what what lasted for good
or ill what has lasted here two
grandparents so people know a lot more
about their grandparents in general
you're asking okay what positive things
that they do that they're still with you
how did they JQ that in ways that you
would want to pass on to others what
challenges did they bring into the table
meaning to almost always not meaning to
if you you've been impacted by decisions
they made it's true for almost everybody
I mean great very rare you have all
positives from your ancestors right
every that would be fantastic
sometimes people do get pretty close to
that but but but moat for most of us
it's pretty dysfunctional family history
once you get back a little ways and it's
same for parents so you you're really
trying to understand what is their
impact what have their decisions been
impact on me positively
negatively now what am i grateful for I
mean I'm a big believer in the idea that
if we're going to blame people we got to
blame them intelligently I watch
somebody talking about this one's had an
impact on me which is if you go to blame
your parents or your grandparents or
something you can blame him for
everything meaning yeah yeah I blame you
for this bad decision but I also blame
you for giving me my life you know I
also blame I blame you for having you
know mess this thing up that's always
made this particular thing hard for me
or for my for my brother father but I
also blame you for the fact that they
turned that around and became strong and
I've always always benefited from that
strength so you blame intelligently you
see the good and the bad you blame and
tells you that you're looking at the
whole picture so that you can see a life
with some sort of perspective mm-hmm and
this is something I learned that the
design school it Stanford I didn't know
it then I was still thinking birth till
death thinking I thought that's pretty
long-term perspective if you're getting
people to think about their whole life
from birth till death you are doing a
good thing and I think it probably was a
good thing and it's certainly far more
long-term than most people think on a
daily basis but it's so insufficient
it's necessary but insufficient we kind
of what a self-centered perspective I
couldn't believe it actually when I
really realized how blind of a
perspective I was suggesting I mean but
like like like my story begins like like
the story of my life is really about me
what a weird thing to think that I it's
about my birth my death and what's
happened in between
the narrative is so much richer than
that and I've got to tap into that so
that as I then move into the future I'm
also doing the same thing so in these
personal quarters off sites it's pushing
yourself beyond that you're saying okay
what what do I want my children
grandchildren generations especially
this idea what do I want my the
generation that has forgotten me
what impact do I want to have on them
yeah if it's true that we can't even
name my great-grandparents then it's
gonna be true that our
great-grandchildren can't won't name up
there than a month or it might be true I
know the true might be true but the
impact doesn't change just the memory
changes its its impact outlast memory
and so and so this perspective this
helps to reveal for us the difference
between good things and essential things
and that's the whole shift you know the
the essentialism is different to every
other productivity system that I'm
familiar with in this primary way it's
not about getting more stuff done it's
about getting more of the right things
done and it's not about efficiently
doing what's on the to-do list it's
realizing but the most important thing
isn't even on the to-do list that's the
insight and that's what the personal
course the off-site can do could you
chat a little bit this is very helpful
about the what makes a good design
partner and what that might look like
how you help each other because Design
Thinking came up a little bit earlier
maybe you could just define that for
folks since it came in the context of
the d.school at Stanford but you know
what what is design thinking and what
makes a good design partner and what
might they ask you or do in a quarterly
off-site okay well let's start with what
makes a bad design partner perfect yeah
a bad design partner a bad friend but
you know relationship is one that they
eats their heart out if you're
successful and has some sort of pleasure
if you're unsuccessful right I guess
that's that's what's that that's that's
like a bad relationship and and and
unfortunately I think because of our
human weakness that that is often what
we're offering you know that's often
what we're offered
and so you got to find that person who
is celebrating your success who wants
your success when you're successful they
don't they don't go genius I'm now
jealous of that huh what's wrong with me
T Chester delighted and I I say this not
in a small way I mean that's I am
fortunate they might design partly right
that's my wife
and it is is this and she has been the
whole time I've ever known and it's been
really amazing and I think often about
how different my life would have been
without her being that design partner
I'm not making some I don't know some
cheap comment or cheap praise me without
her is is not to have written
essentialism no way I most wanted to I
might have thought about it but the idea
of executing that the idea of completing
it the idea of the the key breakthrough
moments it's it's not that she's done it
is that she's believed in me as I've
tried to do these things I mean I read
somewhere that all you need is one
person to believe in you for the rest of
your life to have somebody believe in
you affirm you just not and the weaker
version of that is like don't talk them
down but don't you know why are you
doing that man since we're why would you
want to achieve that there any of that
kind of stuff just to have somebody that
isn't doing that is something but but
that's that is dad has been incredible
useful to me with Emma and so with the
design partner you know that's that's
what you're trying to at least
approximate and so it could it could be
doesn't have to be a spouse of course it
could be it can be a friend it can be it
could be a colleague it could be you
know some it could be a parent it could
be you know anybody but as long as these
are the rules of the road I I think I
think the only other thing I want to say
about the design part is is that one
shouldn't expect the conversations to
all be easy especially if you're
choosing someone who knows you well
because they're a support review doesn't
mean that they're going to say easy
things to you I mean I don't
I mean the idea of having a close
relationship with someone I mean I'm
talking marriage there for some reason
and you reflecting on that the idea that
you can have relationship without having
conflict is absurd there is conflict in
all of life and so having conflict about
what is important it is really to be
expected and to figure out together to
have even what is sometimes painful
conversations Oh what is most important
to us is it this thing or that thing
which is the trade-off how much of this
are we really going to have in our life
this is hard work and it's not one more
thing to do it's like the very work of
life and so with the design partner you
you're engaging you're willing to engage
now in something over time that could be
quite quite tough especially as I say if
you're living together with this look
the output of the decisions you know
those those are some of the things I've
learned that I've thought about but I do
think having a design partner or two is
it can be a good idea there may be maybe
one of the comment about is that maybe
I've been a little idealistic to say it
this way but but having people who can
powerfully listen is got to be a key
element of success with a design partner
to be a powerful listener is is is also
pretty rare there are people that aren't
the second you say well I've been
thinking about this jumping in with
their opinion reading their
autobiography into your life telling you
what you know you got to have space and
and I think it would be better to go on
a personal course with offset on your
own then it would be to go with somebody
who's just going to jump in immediately
and interrupt your thinking and tell
them about what you think and the whole
idea is to create space to be able to
discern that voice we will have lots of
names
right but we're just the voice your own
conscience your own sense of direction
and to be able to listen to that so that
you can discern again between all these
good things all these different tools
and so on and really what it is that you
feel even you you know what you came
here to do and that's the point of it if
there's no one who can help with that
process
go on your own but if you've got
somebody who can do it together with and
you're doing it for them too so it's not
one way you you're being listener for
them and not just what they're saying
but to try and get deeper and to hear
what they're not saying in pursuit of
and if the Quakers have a process it's
very powerful if you even put a link to
this possibly I don't know if I'd get
some notes or whatever but but a process
that they follow called the clarity it's
not the clarity Council but it's
something like that the clarity and it's
they they they have rules these two
rules which is that you're not allowed
to make give any opinion and you're not
allowed to give any advice and advise
any opinion you can only ask honest
questions in pursuit of helping someone
to find clarity and so your goal is not
to persuade them to do something or
persuade them not to do something it is
to ask questions so that they can feel
and get clear on what is they feel right
to do mm-hmm
that is that's again I know I'm talking
high standards I know this is
aspirational things but that's really
what you're trying to get to you're
trying to create an environment I mean I
one of the things I'll do and I
certainly meditate I mean I I pray and
so I pray when I'm on these off sites so
that I can feel that sense of direction
you know I'll read I bring literature
with me that gets me centered what type
of literature any examples yeah I mean
beyond beyond Scripture which I do bring
it to
read it can be it can be you know it's
classic literature it's it's you know
what it's not as as important as what it
is it's not rubbish it's not just
thoughts of the day latest reactive
thing it's you know it's as far away
from the latest news update as I can get
so I just finished reading John Adams
autobiography not automatically
biography by by David McCullough and I
loved that that's a long biography and
by the end of it I just loved John Adams
and loved what he was trying to do and
it inspired me no end to what I want to
be able to do with my you know with my
son I have a son and actually he's a
namesake just like John Adams has John
Quincy Adams and it's just inspiring of
each other Adams reads he was reading
Latin Greek all of these not these
classic texts not just classic texts in
English in their original Greek and
Latin I mean that's amazing it puts me
without excuse something I think okay I
need to give up this kind of junk
gossipy news that that is so easy to get
dragged into multiple times a day
berating everything's breaking news now
everything's breaking breaking news
there's it the most important thing
that's ever happened and it's and when
you you click on the bait what you find
is that somebody is now talking about
someone who was tweeting about somebody
else who was tweeting and that's the
breaking news this is gossip this is
just gossip this is just nonsense
well at least that's how I feel about it
and and and so so that's an example of a
kind of book I would that I would want
to be reading something something that
can that can ground me in principles
that longer-term then hopefully than my
own life I mean that's what I want to be
connected to let's come back to if
you're willing to prayer for just a
second do you have any prayers or types
of prayers that you
I return to more often than others you
know so so prayer for me is what it is
characterized by is not being wrote not
saying I'm sorry
ungodly wrote wrote so so when it's when
it's great it has a single a single test
point which is already kind of mentioned
which is that you can feel that voice of
clarity you can actually send a center
yourself in it okay I can now feel the
difference between all of these voices
around me there's a in my office I have
a picture of by James Christensen has
called the listener and in in the
picture you have the listeners in the
middle is a young man and and around him
he's got all these people it's very
colourful picture he's sitting there
almost did it almost in a sort of
Buddhist seated positions eyes closed to
represent that he's trying to listen to
his voice of conscience instead of all
these other people around him some of
them are laughing some of them are
yelling them shakespeare's in there I
think his mother-in-law was painted in
there you know he's got all these
different people and he's trying to
listen not to all of that but to the
voice within it that's when I know the
prayers working so to speak is that it's
not just sort of one way I'm not just
going through it not going through the
motions if I go through the motions but
when it over the motions then it's not
it's not changing I don't feel different
afterwards you just yeah you're having a
I mean if you if you and I got on the
phone and every time I got on the phone
with you I said exactly the same things
thoughtlessly our relationship would not
be very real you know this would get
very irritating and so so for me you
know it's about the realness I mean I
certainly subscribe to to the idea to
the principle that the state of my heart
before God that matters at any given
moment it's not what I did yesterday
it's not what I did 10 you
good or bad it is this moment and it's
course that's true in every moment this
moment you're conditioned am I am I
willing to admit my vulnerabilities and
that's that's what I'm trying to do in
prayer is look this is what's going on
this is what's a struggle for me this is
what's a trouble and I'm really willing
to do whatever I'm I can hear the voice
of clarity I commit right now I'm doing
it I will do it and if I'm in that state
then it becomes clear what to do and
what not to do and especially important
on something like a personal portly
off-site but also true a course in in
this you know this ongoing journey of
trying to discern not between not just
between us as you could frame it yeah
good and evil maybe is that still it in
some way but really for me I don't think
about it like that I'm trying to discern
between essential and good I'm trying to
say look it's all good I got got a long
list of things I can do today and
there's nothing on it that there's
nothing on this list that's like bad
there's nothing in me I don't personally
struggle with like oh I want to do
something bad in my life I don't feel
that but I want to know between the
essential and the good I want to know
what that is because I don't have time
to get all the good and all the
essential thing that's done I don't have
that time I don't think actually any of
us do I think really we have enough
essential things to fill the rest of our
life and that is precisely why I must go
it's look so so jugular Lee important to
me to to figure it out is because every
time I'm not doing what's essential I am
giving up something that is essential
hmm that's a great way to put it and we
could talk for many many hours we I may
have to at some point ask for a round to
this is incredibly enjoyable and helpful
and I and I thought I would start to
wrap up just by reading a few other
highlights on these many pages in front
of me
and and then we can we can start to put
a close to things but the first is quote
to embrace the essence of essentialism
requires we replace these false
assumptions which previously come up in
the book with three core truths number
one I choose to number two only a few
things really matter and three I can do
anything but not everything and then the
culinary two highlights later on are
quote the ability to choose cannot be
taken away or even given away it can
only be forgotten I think that's really
important and then to become an
essentialist requires a heightened
awareness of our ability to choose and
so I wanted to open the door if you
wanted to to elaborate on that at all
but then also to ask you metaphorically
speaking if you could put you know one
question one line word quote whatever it
might be on a on a gigantic billboard to
reach billions of people what that might
be but that that'll be probably my last
question but the the ability to choose
and how often we forget that we do have
choices we may not love our choices but
nonetheless we do have choices why is it
that we so often feel we do not have
choices or forget that we have choices
well we're creatures of habit and so we
get pulled into into a whole set of
things as if and eventually those habits
are acting on us and so we just really
start to believe I I don't I don't have
a choice I and we say it that way we say
I have to well what we're saying what we
say we have to is there isn't there
isn't there is nothing else that could
be done we I have to means there is no
agency involved there's no choice
involved and I had a great little
experience with this where we had them a
son through it through a funny and and
and welcomed sort of wager that I did
justice friendly silly wager with it
with it with a friend of mine he said we
had this to see if I won the wager then
he would take my son to baseball for the
whole season
and every and and and if I lost I had to
take him to baseball the whole season
which seemed like that was a wager in my
favor but really unlikely that I was
gonna win the weight and at least at
least he thought so and so as it turns
out he lost the wager so he's now doing
this and and so this is all just fun and
games but then as the season began we
realized that we of course had been
conned in our own thinking planning
fallacy of course there's still
requirements for us
it's got like to get him all the
equipment and we're still gonna get him
ready every single time and we still got
to go take him to this still it's not
gonna literally be zero impact
just because someone else is taking them
to the practices and so on and so right
as it came there was so enough going on
in our life it just felt like definitely
one more thing and quite a big one more
thing but here we are we could have said
look we have to do it we don't want to
but we have to and we almost didn't make
that mistake and then we changed the
language you said and this is important
I choose to have a son in baseball
because and we had to fill in the blank
because if we don't he's gonna be really
disappointed by Framing it like that if
you say I have to it just that it's the
end of your reasoning end of your
thinking you can't prosecute the
hypothesis you can't do anything there's
no hypothesis you just send a story by
saying I've chosen do this because he'll
be upset now we could test it now it
could have been upset we didn't know so
we can test it Jack came in here comes
in some we're thinking about this
baseball season we're thinking it might
just be you know one more thing and and
we're just wondering you know what what
are your thoughts about this about you
know if we did it didn't do it what are
your thoughts it instant reaction oh god
be fine that was easy
I saved months of work he was no love
loss from at all that's why we get
caught into this we think we have to do
we don't take responsibility it's a
choice it's a choice because I don't
want this output now let's go and find
out if that output really is what would
happen so I think that that's kind of
where we get into it and in some ways
you could say well that's not what's the
big deal
but it's the it's a huge deal
because at the core of it what we what
we are is our ability to choose that's
who we are
that's what makes us human and so when
we when we remove that when we forget
about it we're removing what makes us
most human and and so that's when we
start living in kind of non-human ways
machine ways robotic ways disconnected
ways disconnected relationships we're
not choosing anymore we are but we're
not doing it very consciously we're
doing it compulsively and that's exactly
the shift did I'd be advocating for I I
rarely advocate explicitly for what I
think is essential or non-essential like
I there's almost there is a there's some
for those that are paying attention in
the book you know some of my values I
think are in there but it's not explicit
I'm not saying how you should value this
thing over that thing but I am
advocating that that people should be
conscious about the value that they are
choosing not compulsive compulsive this
is this is the environment which we
don't know we're choosing we don't we're
not conscious of it and we just become a
function of everybody else's choices and
what everyone else is doing and whatever
we just last thought in our heads kind
of a thing which is a choice in of
itself right if you think you're not
making a choice or you abdicate yourself
from making a choice that is in fact a
choice right you are just putting fate
in the hand of you're in the hands of
other people other forces or
subconscious and so on as opposed to
exerting agency over your set of
circumstances and it's easier to do that
in the short term it feels easier I
don't have a choice see I'm not
responsible I'm not I'm not I'm not on
the hook for this I mean I'm the victim
of everything I mean of course in that
in a sense we don't have to worry as
much because we don't I don't like this
but this is what it is
and and that's all fine if everybody
around us is making the right choices
and society is going in the right
direction and culture is supporting the
highest values and our best contribution
that we could make in life fine but of
course that's not the case and so in a
world where you know that can be tilted
in all sorts of pernicious directions
all sorts of negative themes and
influences if you just go with the flow
yes can't I don't have a choice I think
yeah I think yeah you know you can end
up living a life so differently than the
one you really intended to live that
that you again it's waking up to this I
yes I have a choice I got to make a
choice oh no it might be the wrong
choice I might guess it wrong of course
I am but I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
actually you know to lean into that
reality you can't the one choice you
can't make is to just to get rid of your
ability to choose which account cannot
be done it's like not not theoretically
not practically possible so that's a
good it's good news that this discovery
I am choice whatever has happened to I
can make a different choice going
forward whatever is happened to me
intergenerationally it's full circle
back to this new work that yeah you're
gonna start working on in a new way from
this moment on forever is that we we
don't have to do what happened to us we
don't have to repeat what happened to
our mother father grandfather
grandparent great-grandparents bad stuff
did happen I'm almost certainly but we
can be a transition person we can say I
have a new choice and I choose
differently and and it's so powerful the
moment somebody discovers that from a
weight has an awakening around that
they're able to they're able to move
forward and change everything that comes
after them we didn't talk about it my
family but I'm gonna talk about it my
family we you know this was a black box
and we didn't deal with it but we're
gonna deal with it it's not gonna be
easy but we're dealing with it now so
that it doesn't just get passed on to
the next my great grandkids are still
struggling with this stuff I'm gonna
shift it yeah we had alcoholism and I
family but we I'm not gonna I can choose
not to drink alcohol I can choose not to
pass the song you know see this is this
is
to me empowering inspiring change in
perspective hugely and you like you said
you do have the option to flip the
switch to switch the track to redirect
the Train and you can be that transition
point for yourself and for the people
around you and for the people who come
after you
well Gregg this is this has been such a
a wonderful conversation for me I hope
it was somewhat stimulating or fun for
you to be a part of and perhaps we could
just close on the on the Billboard
question this is it does anything come
to mind is a question a word a lion a
quote anything that you would put on a
billboard as a message to convey to
millions or billions of people liked
liked just that word Li gh t that's it
light is that every moment in our lives
in whatever capacity we're in there is
always this choice in this moment to
step towards light but a step towards
darkness and I don't mean grandiose you
know as I said before massive good
versus massive evil it's not that but
each moment we have the choice do I step
towards the light do I step towards some
dark version of this moment do I do I
get irritated with my kids or do I be
patient
do I do I listen to the voice of
conscience in this moment or do I just
go after what my ego would want me to go
after and my experiences with this and
I'm just just beginning my own journey
of it of course but is that if I if I
pursue what is light it will bring more
likely and that light grows brighter and
brighter and maybe it carries on forever
until the perfect day but that's that's
the idea wherever anybody is that they
can do that right whatever choices
they've made before and all of us have
made mistakes right all of us have
chosen in those moments huh I went down
I was a dark choice I don't mean that
the dark side like
you know like some Star Wars thing where
you go over to the dark side no but just
in this moment I chose the impatient
part they chose the negative part I
chose the self-interested part they
chose the you know or I could just
choose the like in my experiences
wherever anybody is on this journey you
know between light to dark let's say
wherever they are on that continuum the
people that are most full of light
aren't the people who have done all the
best things in their lives necessarily
it's which direction they're headed in
it's which decision they just make and
and and so that's why it's so powerful
it's this is not getting all burdened
about whatever the past has been it's in
this moment am i leaning into the light
or leaning out of it and that to me is
like seriously it's like the whole of
life written in one single rule and and
so that's that that would be I think
that would be you know my answer for
that at least today light I like it well
thank you so much Greg people can find
you online
Greg McEwan comm they can say hello give
a wave on social at Gregory McEwen on
Twitter and probably elsewhere the book
essentialism I highly recommend it and I
don't say that much about many books it
is a it is a very useful book I found it
personally useful it's something that I
revisit as is there anything that you
would like to say in closing remarks
anything else you'd like to add for
people listening and he asked you'd like
to make of them if anything no I I don't
have any ask for them but I do want to
say to him I really appreciate how you
know this conversation I feel like you
know it's it's been I found it more than
a normal podcast kind of conversation
and that's you know that's credit to you
and you know I appreciate it that you
you've brought so much to the
conversation and helped it to be what at
least for me is felt rich and and and
meaningful and real and so so thank you
to you thanks so much Greg this this is
this is
so this is a conversation I think I will
I will certainly listen to again I'll be
revisiting the book I think that's a
good starting point for my next
quarterly off-site and for people
listening I will include links to
everything we discussed of course
everything that Greg is up to the Quaker
process have taken notes on things to
follow up on the piece of artwork you
mentioned as your reference point all of
that will be in the show notes which you
can find at tim blog forward slash
podcast just search essentialism or
Greg's a name and it will pop right up
and I want to mention one more quote
before we close and this is also from
the book it is a quote of Lao Tzu and it
goes as follows quote to attain
knowledge add things every day to attain
wisdom subtract things every day so
until next time folks thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim that blog is built on it the
websites for my books related tools of
Titan's tribe of mentors it's all in or
depressed calm and the founder Matt
Mullenweg when my close friends has
appeared on this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog business sites or both you
can make a really big impact right out
of the box when you build on
wordpress.com
and you'll be in good company it's used
by the New Yorker jay-z Beyonce at 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN and time just to name
a handful and one of my friends at
Google she'll remain nameless has told
his pet bird press calm offers the quote
best out of the box
SEO imaginable and put it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on WordPress you do
not need experience or to hire someone
as perhaps the best part wordpress.com
guides you through the entire experience
they have hundreds of designs and
templates that you can use and it's easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security upgrades posting any of
that they offer 24/7 support and they're
very very responsive to the questions
they get right back to you and this
allows you to create the highest quality
with the least amount of headache and
friction so if you're building a website
period and my friends come to me and ask
what I use what I recommend they use the
answer is wordpress.com so check it out
if you want to get started today learn
more with a 15% discount off any new
plan go to wordpress.com hold slash Tim
create your website and find the plans
right for you to learn more take a look
wordpress.com 4/10 15% off
brand-new website check it out this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably about a
year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient it has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep them motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way and sin defies
me but they really 100% hit the nail on
the head I was very very impressed with
how motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite little easy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this
gasps a limited time offer go to one
palette on Comm that's fo and e palette
on PE l OT o and.com and enter the code
Tim ball caps at checkout and get $100
off of accessories with your policy on
bike purchase so get a great workout at
home anytime you want check it out go to
one peloton calm and use the code Tim to
get started
[Applause]